welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and we're back with
another picaud breakdown our mission is
to boldly go where no one has gone
before and give our thoughts on the new
entry as well as what could be happening
in the future
throughout this video we'll be
discussing the ins and outs of the forth
episodes plot it's Easter eggs and what
we thought of it as a whole we will be
engaging with heavy spoilers here so if
you haven't had a chance to catch the
show yet and don't want to know what
happens then I highly suggest that you
turn off now make sure you subscribe to
the channel for videos like this every
week and without the way I just want to
give a huge thank you for clicking this
now let's get into a breakdown of
Piccard episode 4 ok so just a quick
recap of the series so far after the
death of datastore at dodge the cod made
it his mission to track down a twin
sister solji but Cod wanted to set out
into the stars to locate her and after
being denied by Starfleet he finally got
a crew together to travel to the
vastness of space in order to locate a
episode four centers primarily around
the titular character his crew and a
Romulan orphan named el noir that picaud
helped to rescue during a supernova that
shaped many events in the show the
episode opens with Admiral Picard
travelling to CL noir as a young boy and
he fills in a lot of the blanks from his
past it's revealed that 14 years prior
picaud settled the Romulan refugees on
Vashti there is a mention of 10,000
refugees and this actually ties in
heavily with the prequel comic book Star
Trek the cod countdown in that the
character in a ship the Verity were
asked to evacuate the 10,000 it's during
this mission that he and Rafi were taken
hostage by the Romulan government who
revealed that there were actually five
million inhabitants on the planet that
needed saving but that the Romulans only
wish to save their own people
they defeated the corrupt government and
evacuate the 10,000 and over a quarter
of a million more but as we know
Starfleet was not there to save the rest
of the planet and thus many of the
survivors remained on Basti vashti
itself is named after the first queen of
Persia in the book Esther and during
that the Queen was banished from the
kingdom after refusing to show her PE
during a banquet this is merged slightly
in the episode in which Elinor who
Nessus both the child in adult carries a
lot of disdain for picard
because he believes he was absent Picard
shows up in his fancy suits whilst the
Romulans are forced to live on an
underdeveloped planet and it's clear
that the promises he makes about the
Federation are ultimately shown to be
untruthful the synth attack breaks his
word and this Eleanor grows up disliking
the character after the credits jump to
the present 14 years after the intro we
see Picard returning to Vashti to try
and recruit Eleanor on his mission we
join Rios Reed in the tragic sense of
life which as we discussed last week was
a book on how death gives life purpose
and this is mirrored in Picard's mission
and his now finite time left alive rios
gives a much better description of the
book in the episode than i did but yeah
there's a lot of parallels here his
diagnosis is put a ticking clock on his
life and he seems to be trying to live
out the best of both worlds with the
holodeck placing the character back on
the chateaux once more we learned that
Vashti is in the middle of a power
vacuum run by gangsters and crime lords
and it's basically Mos Eisley but in
Star Trek
Vashti is also part of the Romulan
rebirth movement and is also lip service
paid to the way of absolute candor which
is basically when you have a drink and
go on it to a rant but in real life it's
the opposite of what the Romulans tend
to do as they are normally this strong
and silent type but this allows them to
speak their mind and felt it Raffy tries
to talk Picard out of it and we see how
the death of dodge has made the
character feel like perhaps he has a
chance to redeem himself not only in
Sochi but also in Eleanor once he
arrives on the planet we realized that
though Picard necessarily isn't in the
good books at Starfleet many still view
him as the embodiment of it he stands
there a charming man who is all front
and really just full of empty promises
to the Romulans the fact that he
resigned from Starfleet shows that he
never really had any intention of truly
helping them and was only in it for the
glory
whilst we know that this isn't really
the case and it was more due to being at
his wits end this stepping down has made
you realize that perhaps the character
isn't the selfless pillar of gird that
we once believed him to be back on the
board cubed Sochi is investigating the
past aramta who as we know was part of
the last ship to be
simulated by the station she mentions
the destroyer which she accused Shoji of
being and I actually have a theory that
Shoji maybe the next Borg Queen I keep
meaning to mention this every video but
I keep forgetting so I'm making a point
of doing at this time Shoji can speak to
the drones without knowing how as we
know she is the melding between
synthetic and organic and though I have
seen some people say that this could
make her one of the Borg if you're gonna
go all out then as a show you might as
well have the Queen appear rather than
just a lowly drone she is called the
destroyer which the queen would have a
reputation of being and there's a lot of
way to this theory sprinkled throughout
the episode including the revelation
that she was sent to the cube and not
that she was requested to go there there
are questions about her identity and who
she really is and I think this makes a
lot of sense on a date with Marik she
asks the piece tell she which he says he
isn't but this is then followed up by
him saying that if he was he wouldn't
tell her as we know he is duplicitous
and thus the second answer is more
likely the truth whether it's his
clothes mission or his sister being tied
heavily in with the shadowy organization
it does seem like he's indeed one of
them actually do you think he is falling
for her and who knows he may be
instrumental in her believing picaud we
know his sister is likely going to
become the big bad so it does leave
wiggle room for him to switch sides we
see him and his sister discussing the
fact that they're using Shoji to find a
nest of synthetics which is where she
potentially came from I think this may
be located at free cloud where Bruce
Maddox is as we know due to the ban on
synthetics he traveled into the universe
to continue working on his perfect
machine we discover that narak is
becoming her boyfriend because if she is
pushed to odd she will activate like
dodge did and potentially enable her
combat systems we jump with Picard back
to Vashti and it's a shadow of the
planet that he landed on almost 15 years
prior everyone looks at him like he's
just told them he's gonna be building a
monorail in the area and there are clear
Romulan Oni zones which mirror the
separation of race that used to exist
across the world he's given less time
than he'd hoped for when Rafi sends word
that an incoming bird of prey carries
conch ATAR on it it is an older model
rather than a newer one and it provides
our first big
face battle in the series Elinor doesn't
seem that up for going with Picard and
even becomes more anger that jean-luc
seemingly cared more for his dead friend
Danny did the living child that he made
a promise to he rejects his requests
worse than those people who watch every
video and don't subscribe when I ask
them to and picaud starts trouble in the
town center in order to get him to come
to his aid he rips the Romulans Oni sign
off and enters the bar Picard comes face
to face with the senator from the
aforementioned comic book run we
mentioned earlier and we see that he's
devolved from a high-ranking official to
a man that lives in poverty he
reiterates how angered everyone is over
him Romulan says we've seen or a proud
race and the ex-senator believes that
the Romulans could have actually saved
themselves had they been left to their
own devices instead of being filled with
false hope now a dude thing that this
once more adds way to the theory that
the Romulans actually carried out the
synthetic attack on Mars whilst they
were in the midst of a supernova in
order to make Starfleet look bad and for
the sins to be hated as we know from
Admiral Clancy there were 14 systems
threatening to leave Starfleet that did
not end up going because of the
synthetic uprising and this made
androids banned throughout the universe
we do know that Romulans hate synthetics
and perhaps they hacked them in order to
make the rest of the galaxy join them in
banning the machines I don't want to get
all bush knocked down the towers but
there's definitely a lot more going on
here the fact that their planet was on
the brink of destruction during this
would give them the perfect alibi and
personally I believe that's what
happened anyway we see firsthand that
Eleanor is a brilliant fighter and he
binds himself to Picard in order to
protect him I got a lot of Legolas vibes
here and the cod makes a public apology
like he's just been canceled the show
ends with an epic space battle and an
ally joining the fight with their ship
failing they beam them aboard and it's
revealed to be seven of nine it's an
awesome way to end the episode and it's
great to see her back in a Star Trek
show as for a feelings for Picard Jeri
Ryan recently discussed how she views
him in an interview with IGN which I'll
play right now 7 I think holds Starfleet
and the Federation in large part
responsible for
the universe has is a mess and I think
she's sort of initially she's Picard as
a representation of that she's been
working I think I'm allowed to say with
sort of a group of feet of freedom
fighters called the thunderous Rangers
who are trying to keep some semblance of
order in the mess that is the galaxy
this is the first time that seven and a
car had actually meet they know each
other by reputation and as I said before
the sevens not on the oh he's a god
bandwagon I think initially when she
meets him because she she holds him
partly responsible for what Starfleet
has done in her so we know a lot from
that no they haven't met before I do
think it's going to add an interesting
dynamic to the show as mentioned she
works for a group of freedom fighters
and Picard may even end up reaching out
to her allies in the next episode we see
them traveling to a more offbeat planet
dressed as pirates Athene this is where
they could end up trying to meet the
group I did enjoy the episode so far and
overall the series has been great for me
thank you everyone who stuck with the
channel and I hope you've been enjoying
the recaps too obviously I'd love to
hear your thoughts on Picard so comment
below and let me know and if you want to
catch up on our breakdown so far then
click the playlist which is gonna be
linked at the end every month on the
15th we give away free blu-rays and all
you have to do to be in with a chance of
winning dr. sleep is leave a like and
subscribe with notifications on if you
want to support the channel and get to
see content early then please consider
clicking the join button below you can
also come chat to us on our discord
server or a definition whitey on Twitter
thanks for making it till the end of the
video
I've been definition you've been the
best I'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]
you